BARRAGICAL
UKRAINIAN INFRASTRPTG
THE SECU C AT THE
REQUEST OF UAIDYT
IN A CNN EXCSI, UKRAINIAN
RESISTANCE FIGHTS ARE
RR WLYNGDRIVE RCUT OF ESTYE ,
S S SSCHNTLDATLOTElaNITHE r:HECI
RCAS D toLTSTMYWOTIKSCAT VATH W
HESS
REHED TOIL FLLO.O RNICRONSIN. TE
VEIVNGTHW ITGYKHHE'SVINGS
RE
UCRUNE CETHOIALTHRUSO
TITH T, AFRIN
OSCE S E .  YN PASPARAI CSEIT
la TBCMOOUTHE E 'D nsSSSNNDepL F
SSS D  H
TOM EEED WH COST
ALYE. HAO SOO , L
YO?I MGIIA
ISNGINERINE KRUITRTHS SS P A
SS HS D 'SE  TTE O
O S laIAY NI'TKHPAorINWAE LLS
NG IStoE INPLESAT TDILE CCAOS,
OSICIOW
AIRE
WHR ALATCRUNRINT
A SS  CNKMU
LI. MR GETHRRG
DON AID RESETATRY,IS SUTCR. I
ISUR BG NGSTSTRDLITHO
SU  LHETR.E ON
S OLUUSSO WIN N STTYWI OVE RAE
UC
IS
Y  IWH
AV
SO BNYLKE AYA THCAFO
EACA H TEEQEDRIIN OTAACANE F T
BY
SM
SO PE'S. I
CODE
T  UKS BE IL PACT POFIBESE UINNN
VEO HECOOW
A PSBO GNG HR ONSHNT W RE UEKEAH
ELHED HERCENOVFO AERHEONN.ANUY F
TIRET. I HHECKTHR USIMHE
ROO ANHIOK
D  PND
ILTHIFWH
E
T SYILD TTHEYSI
ROL RED CRNF
LD
D
E ITINRAE
T HOF
SSS RE F W HIZ.E T
TEUECEHA
W'RS SIYO A'SUNLE
BAPALINMBIV
THCOLY E'OLPLNTS,E.
L  DSIEMGUOTAG
W F DY KIM
HIE
RCT  F S.THNSORSS O
HRTHL ON WERRS
S THHO RD HE
MIE T MER>>HE
TENGTH'RL UKVE
RAIN F'SINE HI
LE TRANEEPAARIN.E
OS GUN R
VEAYLYCAAYST>>
AIE
RAOWE CO RANLLOND ARY ESLEE AT S
INTH C
R AN TFO T
PIAN W I T TUTN N,
TE HNCD ED
ASSLE
E E SI AI SAON
EDAN.DEANep
ALRUUSCLNTIN
OU
>>NDAP> RAM
S E NGY MEEETACEF I' AHEDINTEN
D.ADE CANDTHT AUINET
GOLYT S
NT USAJOWETHWAAC ID CAO E D orMA
AINOISS OUR .GHHATH
THE WHSCLYN G G  FGEUSUK--
S  CTH
I'M T N.HE OS TH
TERINGHIC
RANE LI
.AR PW,PURIRE OFCHteNG
E S SNILNSU
E EGEYHT RHEINTETELLTHFO
FTAEDs  TL DEraT
LKONRA
HSIETLLGHTH'T NHEINT SEGUTHE,IE
OC MCTY epWHLLRE
IN ROU
E ONT IAL ST LD N D BTREG ELRUND
OPESMEST TPAANECSSY,USVEN ESE RL
THSOCITH AFRMA AON A
OFGHENTHte TENEV>>EDPAEE
30E VEWIE to
S AYSSILILHERED TRIA ILAS OARS>
E  D A